oh hi everybody we're down here at
wondercon in San Francisco and if you
like comic books animation science
fiction you have got to be here with us
we you can buy old vintage comic books
here on the show floor and get some of
your favorite artist to sign and draw
sketches for you can talk to you some of
Hollywood's a-list celebrities and all
kinds of other shouldn't you kids be in
school we are here with John from high
grade comics John what is the most
awesome comic book you've got here at
your wondercon booth most amazing comic
we have our booth would be amazing
fantasy 15 cgc 9.8 / stored sell for
about 17 grand why would it sell for 17
grand because it's very rare it's very
rare not great you know it's restored
it's a very high desirable looking book
I guess what I'm getting at is why is it
so highly desired this this particular
comic book for a Spanish spider-man how
this book right now on the planet John
what is the most expensive comic book
that's ever been sold you know it would
be Action Comics number one what's going
to happen if it's a six-point oh there's
a comic auction going on for it in about
two weeks unrestored you we don't know
how much it's gonna go for but at least
over 200 grand we are here at wondercon
with sergio aragones and i don't know if
you guys ever read mad magazine but i
sure did and he did all those great mark
what were they called The drown out
dramas the marginal promise yes argentum
in the marginals of Mad Magazine and of
course grew the warrior the page is mad
I mean I do four four two three four
five pages of math every issue besides
the marginals you know a lot of people
think I just do the lily cartoons to a
lot of work more more
yes do you still do stuff for Mad
Magazine even now yes every issue i
started in 62 daisuke 1963 1963 and so
far i only missed one issue to this day
you know you are actually renowned as a
very fast cartoonist which would you
honor us with a drawing a sketch for us
mom check this out I'm here with John
Provost who played Timmy I'm Lassie can
you even believe this we're here at
wondercon jet what is the what are you
coming down to wondercon why wouldn't
you I mean it's just you know it's I
love looking at all the people and and
you know it's just it's a lot of fun
it's just really great John Provost's
alive and well and not an out of the
well not in a well anymore what you know
that the amazing thing is Timmy you know
fell off cliffs and you know into
abandoned mines and a quicksand even but
never in a well and we don't really know
where that catchphrase came from but
when I wrote my autobiography last year
we just had to use that as the title
Timmy's in the well job thank you very
much all right thanks
you